we had your wife Michelle on the show
and she had mentioned that for about 10
years with the marriage she really
didn't like you oh man um so asking for
a friend how do you get back in good
graces let me let me just say this
Barack Obama reacting to wife Michelle's
past feelings about their marriage and
admits the role he played in her
frustrations she is a little more
forgiving about all my flaws it all went
down during an interview with CBS
morning's co-host Nate Burleson Nate
goes on to bring up this moment last
year when Michelle gets real about their
30-year marriage on Revolt TD people
think I'm being catty by saying this
it's like there were 10 years well I
couldn't stand my husband
you know who say that
and guess when it happened when those
kids were little Barack responds by
giving his take on how they moved on
from that rough patch let me just say
this uh it sure helps to be out of the
White House
uh and uh to to have a little more time
with her right you know what also helps
though about children and yeah I don't
know about your spouse
Michelle
when when our girls were growing up
that was priority number one two
three and four of course Barack and I we
spend most weekends we're staring at
each other because somebody's at a
basketball game somebody's at a dance
somebody's sleeping over we're the last
people our kids want to be with so I
think they're conditioning us for that
emptiness syndrome well now that Sasha
and Malia are out of the house the
former president shares what he's
realized in hindsight I did not fully
appreciate I think as as engaged of a
father as I was
the degree of stress and tension for her
knowing that not just me and Michelle
were under scrutiny and in this strange
environment but that we were raising our
daughters of course and and
a kind of uh situation that just wasn't
normal adding that now Michelle's more
forgiving of his flaws you know what
she's told me is you know looking back
you did okay as a dad yeah and uh and
and if I passed that test then then uh
she'll forgive me most of my other my
other uh affordables yeah and despite it
all the world truly knows how Michelle
feels about her man Barack marriage
isn't 50 50. ever ever there are times
I'm 70 he's 30. there are times he's 60
40. but guess what 10 years we've been
married 30. wow I would take 10 bad
years or over 30. it's just how you look
at it he's a stylish man who is healthy
and he's smart and he's passionate and
he's inspiring and who wouldn't fall in
love with that you know it's okay
[Music]
okay